the Jonas Brothers have another hits
just in time for summer I'm feeling so
cool cool Nick Joe and Kevin Jonas
dropped the visuals for their new song
cool and as the title suggests the Joe
Broz are living their best lives in the
Miami Sun oh yes the only thing that
could have been just a little bit cooler
would have been another J sister feature
man whoa sophie Turner Danielle and
Priyanka Jonas did not appear in the
second music video Nick and Joe hinted
at their leading ladies in the very best
way take a listen
[Music]
now that's a clear reference to Jos
Beyonce sophie Turner show where she
plays Sansa Stark yeah and earlier this
week you guys Joe stepped out to support
Sophie at the Game of Thrones premiere
in NYC the couple actually this is kind
of hilarious ran into Sophie's former
on-screen husband Jack Gleeson aka King
Joffrey at the after-party and Joe
captioned this pic WTF i thought this
dude was dead yeah like crazy what is he
doing just so good I know but Sophie had
nothing but praise for her soon to be
husband when et caught up with her on
the red carpet brought Joe with you
tonight what does it mean for you to
have him be here and support you and how
are you feeling about your relationship
right now it means so much to have him
here it's just like the best support the
best person to calm me down and keep me
calm and if I end up crying I have a
shoulder to cry on so it's good I'm so
happy that he's here and et was thrilled
to find out Joe was actually on set for
the final season the game of Thrones but
don't get any ideas he's not gonna be
spilling any t nada
Joe I didn't just tell him Joe was on
set I stood at the time so he kind of
figured it out and he was like can you
fill me in and he signed an NDA and it
India and everything so I are like it's
all good and Joe and Sophie's big day
will include one of our favorite Starks
he was telling me if she's already
starting to think about what she's gonna
wear to your wedding
good what I don't know why she's
thinking about I'm giving her the
bridesmaid dress
she gonna be one of your bridesmaid yes
she's my maid of honor one of two so
cute can you imagine those pictures I
know I can't wait to see maid of honor
beautiful bride these two I love them I
know not to be left out of this hole
cuteness overload though Nick seemingly
dropped a more indirect line about his
wife Priyanka so Nick singing about a
red dress could be two things as a job
rose fan is it a nod to the classic
burning up
[Applause]
or Priyanka traditional red dress that
she wore at her mini wedding
celebrations I don't know what do you
think Katie I kind of think both but if
I have to pick one it's the wedding
dress right yeah I kind of wanted to be
burning up but I know that's why I do
this so yes I know so obviously we are
all about the Jonas Brothers come back
but we're not the only ones Justin and
Haley Bieber seemed to be very into this
check out this video that Justin just
posted and this isn't the first time a
few weeks ago the Biebs also posted this
getting his wife to admit she was a Joe
Broz fan back in the day what what what
what what the cutest the most hilarious
it really is cute I mean we can't fall
behind the Bieber for being a fan a lot
of the girls were Joe Broz fan but I
love that Justin is like giving her a
hard time about it yeah yeah well all
right guys for all the latest on the
Jonas Brothers Justin and Hailey Bieber
and your other favorite celebs make sure
you subscribe to ET until next time I'm
Courtney teza know I'm Katie Krause bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]